Big Θ is just one of a bunch of different functions that we can define,
and there's a set that essentially corresponds to all the different ways you might
want to compare a function.
If f(n) is in little o(g(n)), that's kind of like saying f(n) is strictly less than g(n).
It grows less slowly asymptotically.
F(n) is in O(g(n))--there's our friend O--that's really like saying f(n) ≤ g(n).
It might grow as fast as g(n), but it might be small.
Θ is the one we just looked at, which kind of like equality--they grow roughly at the same rate.
Ω--f(n) is in Ω(g(n)) means that it is an upper bound.
F(n) is bigger than or equal to g(n).
G(n) is a lower bound on f(n).
The ω, analogously, is kind of like strictly greater than.